[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا الكرام انا طاهر بركه
احييكم وانا راويه الق
اسم الخبر
منكم جميع جوان
بها
عكس التيار الاوروبي ويبحث من تكيين عن
طريق للسلام في اوكرانيا
على الديمقراطيه
زعيم طالبان يسعى لتحويل قندهار مركزا
للحكم بنقل المتحدثين الرسميين ومسؤولين
الاعلام اليها من كابول
وتتابعون معنا الليله ايضا
في كوريا الجنسيا
المدافع الاول ضد حظر تطبيق تيك توك وهي
نفسها تحضره في الصين
على الرغم من الاستبعاد الاوروبي لاي دور
صيني لتسويه في اوكرانيا الا ان للرئيس
الفرنسي رايا اخر فقد راى انه يمكن لبكين
ان تلعب دورا
رئيسي طريق يؤدي الى السلام
في
زيارته للصين ان بكين باقتراحها خطه سلام
قد اظهرت اراده لتولي مسؤوليه تجاه هذا
الملف كما تابع امام الجاليه الفرنسيه في
العاصمه الصينيه ان الخطه الصينيه يمكن
لها ان تكون محاوله لشق طريق يؤدي الى
السلام لافتا الى ان الحوار مع الصين
ضروري حيث لا يمكن ترك الساحه لروسيا ياتي
الكلام الفرنسيه راويه بعد اسبوع من
استنكار غربي لاي دور صيني بمبادره سلام
في اوكرانيا بسبب موقفها الداعم للروس فقد
اعترف بار المسؤول السياسه الخارجيه
بالاتحاد الاوروبي الاسبوع الماضي ان
الصين لا يمكن ان تكون وسيطا في الحرب
الدائره في اوكرانيا الانحيازها الكبير
الى روسيا على حد وصفه الا ان مكرونه الذي
يسبح عكس التيار الاوروبي قد يجد منفع
اقتصاديه اذ يبحث الرجل عن علاقات
اقتصاديه متوازنه مع الصين على حد قوله
[موسيقى]
سيدنا
تفرقهما السياسه لكن تجمعهما المصالح
الاقتصاديه الاتحاد الاوروبي والصين
يحاولان ايجاد طريق سالكه للشراكه
المستقبليه في غابه دوليه تحكمها الصراعات
والتطاحنات العلاقات الاقتصاديه بين بيكين
وبروكسل وثيقه رغم نمو تيار داخل الاتحاد
يدعو الى تقليل التعامل معها فقبل حوالي
سنتين تمكنت الصين من تبوء مكانه الشريك
التجاري العالمي الاول للمنطقه الاوروبيه
خلفا للولايات المتحده
حاملا ملفات السياسه والاقتصاد حل الرئيس
الفرنسي ايمانويل ماكرون بالصين الى جانب
رئيسه المفوضيه الاوروبيه ارسولا فون التي
استبقت رحلتها بخطاب اكدت فيه ان على
اوروبا اللجوء الى ادوات دفاعيه جديده في
علاقتها مع التنين الاسيوي وما تقصده هو
وقف تصدير التكنولوجيا الحساسه الى الصين
وتقليل الاعتماد على الاستيراد منها ما
اعتبره السفير الصيني لدى بروكسل انتهاكا
لقواعد التجاره الدوليه
الرئيس الفرنسي ومن خلال هذه الزياره يسعى
للاستمرار بالدفع باتجاه ولوج افضل الى
السوق الصينيه كما انه لا ينسى السياسه
والحرب في اوكرانيا فحسب ماكرون بيكين
يمكنها ان تؤثر في صنع السلام بسبب قربها
من موسكو
لقد اثرت الحرب التي قادتها روسيا في
اوكرانيا بشكل عميق على النظام الدولي
الذي عرفناه منذ عام 19
هذه الحرب انتهكت العديد من مبادئ ميثاق
الامم المتحده والتي يجب علينا الدفاع
عنها بحزم لذا يمكن للصين على وجه التحديد
بسبب علاقاتها الوثيقه مع روسيا ان تلعب
دورا رئيسيا زياره ماكرون
فيه الصراع بين الولايات المتحده والصين
سواء في شان ما تراه واشنطن مسانده صينيه
لروسيا في حرب اوكرانيا او الخلاف بشان
تايوان
تصعد اجراءاتها الاقتصاديه والتجاريه
اتجاه وتضغط على حلفائها الاوروبيين للحد
من علاقاتهم التجاريه والاقتصاديه مع
الصين لكن منطق المصالح يجعل هذه العلاقه
اقتصاديه اولا واخيرا
بلال الوجداني العربيه
مباشره الى هذا المؤتمر صحفي لرئيس مجلس
النواب الامريكي بالمقار ورئيس تايوان
فهو رئيس يلعب دورا اساسيا
بالشراكه مع الكونجرس في حمايه وتحصين
العلاقات التي تجمع الولايات المتحده مع
تايوان في هذه الاوقات التي نشهدوا فيها
تغيرا في الدبلوماسيه
كانت هناك تاكيدات من الرئيس ريجان سابقا
بان بموجب قانون تايوان الذي تمت مصادقته
من قبل الكونجرس وساهمت لوضع اللبنى
الاساسيه لهذه العلاقه التي جمعتنا لعقود
من الزمن حافظنا خلال تلك الفتره على
استقباب سلامي والازدهار
وارسائد ديمقراطيه في تايوان
لكن لم يعد خافيا عليكم اليوم ان السلام
الذي تنعمنا به والديمقراطيه التي عملنا
بجد من اجل الحصول عليها
يواجهان تحديات غير مسبوقه
مره اخرى نجد انفسنا في عالم حال
الديمقراطيه الاخرى موضعه تهديد
ومساله الحفاظ على
مكانتنا كمناره لل ديمقراطيه تتعرض متى
تتعرض للتهديدات قال الرئيس ريجن ما يلي
الحريه هي ليست نموذج
لجيل واحد وبعدها تنقرض يجب ان تكون ابديه
ولابد من الدفاع عنها بصوره مستمره من قبل
كافه الاجيال
من خلال المناقشات مع زعماء الكونغرس هذا
الصباح دعوني اكرر التزامي تايوان في
الدفاع عن الوضع السلمي الحالي حيث ان
الشعب التايواني سوف يعمل على العمل
لتحقيق مجتمع منفتح وحر وكذلك شددته في
حديث
الى ما ذكره
الرئيس الريجان في مقوله بانه من اجل
الحفاظ على السلم لابد لنا ان نكون اقوياء
وهنا اود ان اضيف باننا سوف نكون اكثر قوه
عندما نكون معا
ومن هذا المنطلق لابد لان اعبر عن امتنان
نيابه عن الشعب التايواني لاعضاء الكونجرس
في الموجودين في هذه القاعه والذين
شاركونا في الحوار من الحزبين هناك جمله
من المبادرات التي تم طرحها من اجل جعل
تايوان ومبادرتنا اكثر قوه ولا سيما تلك
المبادره المتعلقه بتعزيز قدرات الدفاع
الجوي في تايوان
وهي جزء من الروابط الاقتصاديه التي
تجمعنا ودعم في دعم
ومشاركتها في الاسره الدوليه لابد لي ايضا
ان اعبر عن اهتمامنا في تحقيق السلام
والازدهار في منطقه المحيط الهادي
لتكون شريكا يوثق به من قبل العالم ومقرا
للاستقرار في تلك المنطقه وبكل تاكيد
ابعد من ذلك في الختام
هناك
مقوله دائما لا نسمعها باننا لن نكون
لوحدنا وفي سياق مساعينا لحمايه طريقه
حياتنا فاننا متاكدون بان الولايات
المتحده سوف تكون معنا في ظل مواجهه هذه
التحديات الغريبه والفريده من نوعها في
هذا الزمن لابد لنا ان نتذكر المبادئ التي
شكلت هذه الشراكه العظيمه متذكرين الدروس
التي رسمها الرئيس رويجان من خلال تركته
الكبيره مره اخرى شكرا
رئيس المجلس مكارتي على صداقاتكم واود ان
اشكر كافه اصدقائي في الكونغرس للوقوف مع
تايوان شكرا جزيلا
القدر من هذا المؤتمر الصحفي الذي جمع
رئيس مجلس النواب الامريكي كيفن مقارتي
وايضا رئيسه تايوان في هذا الاجتماع كان
استقبلها
بمكتبه رونالد ريجن الرئاسيه وهذا
الاجتماع اصلا اثار حفيظه الصين حتى قبل
انعقاده صحيح وهو كذب اكبر شخصيه امريكيه
تلتقي برئيس لتايوان منذ عام 79 على
الاراضي الامريكيه كما ذكرنا هما في
كاليفورنيا نتابع حيث قال امين عام الناتو
يانس ستولت ان مساعده الصين لروسيا ستكون
خطا تاريخيا وبشان انضمام الى الحلف اضاف
ستولتنبرغ ان اوكرانيا ستصبح جزءا من
الحلف يوما ما
مستقبل اوكرانيا يقع ضمن محيطها في اوروبا
والمحيط الاطلنطي وانضمام اوكرانيا للحلف
يتطلب ان تكون مستقله وغير معرضه للغزو
الروسي وهي ستصبح جزءا من الحلف يوما ما
اتفقنا على تطوير برنامج استراتيجي على
مدى سنوات للارتقاء باوكرانيا لمستوى
الحلف اود الاشاره الى ان مساعده الصين
لروسيا ستكون خطا تاريخيا
وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه قال في ختام
اجتماعات وزراء خارجيه الناتو في بروكسل
ان بوتين يعاني من انتكاسات في حربه
باوكرانيا ولذلك يقذف المدنيين ويعمل على
رفع اسعار الطاقه
المهتمون بمنطقه المحيطين الهندي والهادي
ونرحب بمشاركه اليابان واستراليا
واليوزيلندا وكوريا في قمه حلف الناتو
المقبله والحلف اليوم اقوى واكثر اتساعا
من اي وقت مضى وسنقدم مساعدات اوكرانيا
تسمح لها بحمايه المدنيين من هجمات
المسيرات بوتين فشل في تحقيق اهدافه في
اوكرانيا ويعاني من انتكاسات بحربه هناك
لذلك يعمل على رفع اسعار الطاقه وموسكو
تستخدم الاحتياطيا ماليه بسبب العقوبات
اعلن رئيس البولنديه
لتسليم كل مقاتلاتها من طراز ميج 29 الى
اوكر انيا مستقبلا واضاف خلال مؤتمر صحفي
مع نظيره الاوكراني ان بولندا سترسل ست
مقاتلات من طراز 29 قريبا ليرتفع الاجمالي
الى 14 وقريبا ستكون مستعده لتسليم كل
اسطولها من هذه المقاتلات الذي يضم 30
طائره لاوكرانيا
[موسيقى]
من مخزوناتنا تم ارسالها للقوات المسلحه
للاوكرانيه في الاشهر الاخيره اربع طائرات
ميك اخرى تم ارسالها مؤخرا هذا يعني ان
الاجماليه ثمانيه نحن مستعدون وكنت اتحدث
مع الرئيس بشان ذلك اليوم مستعدون لتسليم
صدق طائرات اخرى ويتم تجهيزها الان لذا
نعتقد انه من الممكن ان يكون التسليم في
المستقبل القريب
زياره الرئيس الاوكراني الى اوكرانيا ربما
ستزيد من اهميه البولندا تحديدا ستزيد من
اهميه دور بولندا اقليميا ودوليا بحسب
صحيفه نيويورك تايمز الصحيفه اعادت
التذكير بان رئيس الحكومه البولنديه
كان احد ثلاثه زعماء اوروبيين وصلوا الى
كياف بعد ثلاثه اسابيع من بدء الحرب وفي
الشهر التالي وصل الرئيس اندريدودا للقاء
نظيره
الاوكرانيندا التي تم استبعادها لسنوات من
قبل القوى الاوروبيه واداره باراك اوباما
باعتبارها معاديه للروس تشعر بحسب نيورك
تايمز بانها كانت محقه في تحذيرها مما
تطلق عليه وارسو الخطر الروسي وتحذيرها من
الاعتماد على روسيا بشكل كبير ومنذ بدء
الحرف في اوكرانيا بات الموقف البولندي
اقوى جزئيا بسبب اشتراكها مع اوكرانيا
بحدود طولها 531 كيلومترا وعبر هذه الحدود
ما يقترب من 90% من المساعدات العسكريه
والانسانيه المقدمه لاوكرانيا الدوره
الجديد لبولندا دفعها لطموح لان تصبح ايضا
قوه عسكريه اوروبيه مع سعي الحكومه
البولنديه الى مضاعفه حجم جيشها الدائم
وتطويره باحدث الاسلحه الغربيه وعلى ان
يكون لدى بولندا قوه بريه ستكون الاكبر في
القاره الاوروبيه بولندا قالت انها تخوض
حروبا على عده جبهات فهي من ناحيه ترسل
كميات كبيره من الاسلحه والذخيره الى
اوكرانيا كما انها تؤوي اكثر من مليون
و300 الف لاجئ اوكراني لكن تطلعات بولندا
للعب دور اكبر في السياسه الخارجيه
الاوروبيه تعرضت للخطر بسبب الصراع الطويل
مع الاتحاد الاوروبي فمنذ عام 2021 عندما
حجبت بروكسيل 35 مليار يورو من المنح
والقروض المستحقه لبولندا ردا على فشل
الحكومه البولنديه في التراجعي عن اصلاح
نظامها القضائي
[موسيقى]
في العربيه 360 ايضا ادانه دوليه لعنف
اسرائيل المتصاعد ضد الفلسطينيين بالقدس
ودعوات لحكومه نتنياهو بالتراجع والتهدئه
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد فاز الرئيس الامريكي
السابق دونالد ترامب قضائيا على الممثله
ستورمي دانييلز فقد قضت محكمه الاستئناف
في كاليفورنيا راويه بان تدفع دانيال مبلغ
120 الف دولار لترامب لقاء اتعاب المحاماه
في دعوى التشهير التي اقامتها ضده وخسرتها
ليكون اجمالي المبلغ الذي ستدفعه دانييل
والاستئناف الاخر
صرح الرئيس الامريكي السابق دونالد ترامب
عبر منصه تروس انه يجب على جمهوريين في
الكونجرس الغاء تمويل وزاره العدل ومكتب
التحقيقات الفيدرالي حتى يعودوا هكذا قال
كما اضاف ترامب ان الديمقراطيين استخدموا
النظام القانوني كالسلاح ولن يسمح الشعب
بذلك الرئيس السابق اشار ايضا الى ان كل
المحللين القانونيين والسياسيين اكدوا له
ان التهم الجائره بحقه ليست متينه وان تلك
التهم ليست جريمه
34 تهمه راويه وجهها مدعي عام منهاتا
للرئيس السابق دومال ترامب لكن يوجد شيء
مفقود في اللائحه بحسب تقرير لصحيفه وولد
رغم طول لائحه الاتهام الا انها لم تحمل
الكثير من المفاجات على فكره خاصه مع
اسابيع من التكهنات والتسريبات قالت ان
المدعي العام الفن براج لم يجب على تساؤل
حول الجريمه الثانيه بمعنى انه اذا تمكن
من اثبات تزوير السجلات التجاريه وهي جنحه
في نيويورك فيجب عليه اثبات ان التزوير تم
بقصد ارتكاب جريمه اخرى او المساعده في
ارتكابها او التستر عليها كان من المتوقع
ان براج سيتهم ترامب بانتهاك قوانين تمويل
الحملات الانتخابيه وهو ما حدث لاخفاء امر
دفع مبلغ
130,000 دولار عن جمهور الناخبين وفي
مؤتمره الصحفي امس كان لدى المدعي العام
فرصه للحديث عن
الاخرى التي كان من المفترض ان الرئيس
السابق يتستر عليها الا ان المدعي العام
تحدث فقط عن السقف او الحد الاقصى فيدرالي
المسموح بتقديمه للحالات للحملات
الانتخابيه
ومخالفه القوانين قوانين ولايه نيويورك
اضاف المدعي العام ان قانون انتخابات
ولايه نيويورك يجرب التامر للترويج للترشح
بوسائل غير قانونيه مذكرا بالاقرارات التي
قدمتها مؤسسه ترامب بشان الاموال التي
دفعت للممثله
[موسيقى]
اذا اقتحام جديد من القوات الاسرائيليه
للمسجد الاقصى تزامنا مع وجود مصلين
معتكفين في داخله نستمع الى صوت طبيعي
[تصفيق]
السلام عليكم ورحمه
الله طبعا كانت اقوات الاسرائيليه بدات
هذا الاقتحام امس
واعتقلت العديد من المصلين داخل المسجد
الاقصى ومنعت صلاتهم الان نفس المشهد
يتكرر تقتحم بحات المسجد الاقصى وتمنع
المصلين من الاعتكاف كان هناك مواقف عربيه
ودوليه مندده حتى البيت الابيض عبر عن
قلقه من تطورات هذه الاحداث وشدد على
ضروره خفض التصعيد بين الفلسطينيين
والاسرائيليين وجامعه دول العربيه كذلك
سنعود الى هذه الاخبار لاحقا في سياق هذه
الساعه اذا نتابع في هذه الصور التي تردنا
الاقتحام جديد من قبل القوات الاسرائيليه
لباحات المسجد الاقصى لمنع المصلين من
الاعتكاف في هذه الليالي المباركه من شهر
رمضان الكريم وتحديدا امس طاهر يعني حدثت
الاعتداءات بعد انتهاء صلاه الفجر حيث كان
هناك اقتحام لضباط
الاسرائيليه ادوات الاسرائيليين وعناصر من
الشرطه لساحات الحرم
وكان هناك مهاجمه للمصلين الصائمين
بالاعير المطاطيه والقنابل الصوتيه مباشره
بعد انتهاء صلاه الفجر اذن البيت الابيض
كان عبر عن قلقه من تطورات الاحداث في
المسجد الاقصى وشدد على ضروره خفض التصعيد
بين الفلسطينيين والاسرائيليين بدوره اعرب
الامين العام للامم المتحده انطونيو
غوتيريش عن صدمته وذهوله ايذاء مستوى
العنف الذي استخدمته قوات الامن
الاسرائيليه بحق مصلينا فلسطينيين داخل
المسجد الاقصى
المتحدث ان الامين العام شاهد صور العنف
والضرب داخل الموقع المقدس ووصف الوضع
بالمحزن والماساوي
معنا الان زياد حلبي مراسل العربيه مباشره
من القدس اهلا بك زياد اريد ان ابدا معك
باخر المعلومات حول ما يحصل هناك من
اقتحام جديد ماذا لديك
القوات الاسرائيليه اعاده اقتحام القبلي
في المسجد الاقصى المبارك حيث كان
يتواجد فيه عدد كبير من البصلين وذلك لمنع
الاعتكاف في المسجد الاقصى حتى صباح الغد
موعد تجدد اقتحامات
المتطرفين اليهود ايضا في مناسبه عيد
الفصح اليهودي ولهذا تحاول اخلاء عمليا
المسجد القبلي والساحات الاقصى من المصلين
اعتدت بالضرب على بعض واطلقت ايضا قنابل
الصوتيه في داخل المصلى القبلي حيث ما
يزال التوتر السيده للموقف هناك زياد يعني
رغم ما لقته هذه
الاقتحامات المتكرره انه اليوم هو الثاني
من حمله ادانات عربيه وعالميه واسعه تكررت
يعني ما التبرير الذي تعطيه القوات
الاسرائيليه لذلك
هي لا تعطي تبريرات عمليا هذه معركه من
نوع اخر في المسجد الاقصى طبعا بحسب
القانون الدولي هو يقع في القدس الشرقيه
المحتله واسرائيل تحاول ان تفرض نوع من
السياده على المكان ولو كانت ابنيه ولهذا
هي تحرص على ان تمنع اي شيء خارج
السيطرتها في داخل المسجد الاقصى حتى ولو
كان اعتكافا للمصلين ولهذا يتكرر الموضوع
في وخاصه عندما تكون هناك مناسبات يهوديه
دينيه الامر ياخذ ابعاد اخرى ويزداد
التوتر
وتزداد المواجهات في مثل هذه
الاحوال طبعا
الشرطه اعلنت عن 350 شخص اوقفته اوقفتهم
في الحرم القدسي مع انه في بعض الكلام عن
انه العدد اكبر من ذلك ما بين 450 الى 500
هذا اي حدا كان بالامس الاعتقال حوالي 400
الى 500 معظم هؤلاء اخرج خرج من الاعتقال
ولكن ولكن بشرط طبعا
بمعنى يتم ابعادهم عن المسجد الاقصى حتى
البلده القديمه في القدس الشرقيه
المحتله
وبطبيعه الحال هذا الاجراء سيتكرر ولكن
بدون ما رايناه بالامس على الاقل كان ربما
القمع الاعلى ربما الاعتداء الاعلف على
ومن فيه منذ العام الفين لم نرى هذه
المشاهد بهذه القوه على الاقل ولهذا ايضا
رايت ان ذلك فعل جبهه قطاع غزه في اطلاق
الصواريخ على فكره الليله ايضا اطلقت
ساروخان من قطاع زياد ونحن نتحدث معك
نشاهد هذه الصور
للاعتداء على المصلين من داخل المسجد
الاقصى ومنعهم من الاعتكاف هذه اذا القوات
الاسرائيليه لليوم الثاني على التوالي قلت
له عن مجلس عن عقد مجلس الامن وجلسه طارئه
غدا بطلب فلسطيني اردني مشترك لبحث
الاقتحام الاسرائيلي المسجد الاقصى
على هذا الموضوع كانت راويه ابرز الاصابات
بالامس في الجزء العلوي من الجسم كما تحدث
احد المحامين عن المعتقلين لاسيما في
الراس والعيون حتى انه جمعيه اسعاف الهلال
الاحمر تحدثت عن تعامل طواقيمها مع 25
اصابه من الذين اخرج عنهم ونخلق منهم الى
المستشفى لا نعرف حتى الان بخصوص الاعداد
اليوم في هذا الاقتحام الثاني المتجدد على
المعتكفين يعني هذا
هذا
نشاهد اذا هذه الصور صور جديده للقوات
الاسرائيليه تقتحتحن المسجد الاقصى زياد
يعني كان هناك حديث انه الان انطلقت مسيره
لالاف يعني صور قاسيه جدا في هذا الشهر
الفضيل واطلاق للنار
والرصاص المطاطي على المصلين الذين يعني
كل ما يفعلوه هو اقامه الصلاه والاعتكاف
رغم تاكيد رئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلي بعد
الاقتحام بالامس بانه اسرائيل ملتزمه
الحفاظ على حريه العباده وحريه الوصول
لجميع الاديان الى المسجد طبعا وانها لن
تسمح للمتطرفين العنيفين بتغيير هذا هنا
نسال زيار تطرفا منه تحرجه
هذا طبعا نسبي التطرف في هذه الحال
بطبي
عه المسجد الاقصى لكن بدون مشاكل بانه
عندما تضع شخص بمتطرف بحجم بين كبير
مسؤولا عن الموضوع الامني اساسا الداخلي
لهذا هو وزير الامن القومي وهو المسؤول عن
الشرطه الاسرائيليه بهذا المعنى هذا قد
يعطي دفعا معنويا كبيرا لليمين الاسرائيلي
المتطرف للتذكير فقط عمليا لاننا نشاهد
هذه صور من داخل المسجد الان نستمع الى
الصوت الطبيعي
الغريب راويه ان نتنياهو في بيانه كان
نتحدث عن اجراءات اسرائيليه للحفاظ على
الوضع الراهن وتهدئه النفوس بعد ما اشاد
وزير الامن الداخلي الاسرائيلي تمارن كثير
بالشرطه لتحركها السريع والحازم متهما
المصلين انفسهم الذين طردتهم الشرطه من
المسجد بنيتهم الحق الاذى برجال الشرطه
يبدو زياد ان نتنياهو بوعده في البيان
هذا صحيح وهذه الوعود اساسا ليست يعني ذات
قيمه كبيره لانه عمليه هذا الامر يتكرر كل
سنه هذا ليس
استثناء ما يحدث ربما عنف القمع
الاسرائيلي هذه المره والاعتداءات هي اوسع
نطاقا هذا واضح
رايناه بالامس وربما ما ترونه الان مباشره
هذا يدلل على هذا الامر لكن بدون ان لان
هناك شعور لدى اليمين المتشدد والمتصرف في
اسرائيل بان هناك دفع معنوي بسبب انه
يسيطر على هذه الحكومه للتذكير فقط ربما
ما يستشعر بسببه المقدسيون والفلسطينيون
بالخطر الشديد هو ان هناك ايضا
تحريض يميني دائم على الانتهاكات في
الاقصى ذبح قرابين وما الى ذلك اليوم
اعتقل مستوطن كان يحمل
جديا اراد ان يقدمه قربانا في المسجد
الاقصى هذه الامور عمليه تضع
[موسيقى]
في قمه التوتر في هذا المكان
نعم زياد يعني عاده بعد هذه الاقتحامات
بيكون هناك مسيرات للالاف من الفلسطينيين
في باحات المسجد الاقصى باختصار لو سمحت
هذا لمن يستطيع ان يبقى هناك عاده يتم
اخراج منهم في المصلى القبلي ومن هم في
الساحات لكن عاده
يعني تيسر لهم البقاء في السحاب قلنا بشكل
تلقائي احيانا بعد الصلاه يمكن ان يكون
هناك هتافات وما الى ذلك كما راينا ايضا
اليوم في مكانه القوات السعوديه تحاول
اقتحام المسلط شكرا جزيلا لك زياد حلبيين
نذكر طاهر بانه القوات الاسرائيليه تستخدم
الرصاص المطاطي وقنابل الغاز كما نشاهد في
هذه الصور والمزيد حول تطورات الوضع في
المسجد الاقصى
وهناك جلسه طارئه كما ذكرنا لمجلس الامن
حول هذا الاقتحام على راس الساعه
[موسيقى]
بالعوده الى واشنطن وردود الفعل
المتزايده على محاكمه ترامب التاريخيه
معنا من هناك ريتا سليمان مراسله العربيه
ريتا يجب ان نختصر بسبب النقل المباشر
اعذرينا ولكن لو تختصري لنا اهم يجب ان
يعلموا المشاهد العربي الليله عن تطورات
هذه القضيه اليوم
اليوم وبعد
حوالي 24 ساعه على المحاكمه التي وصفت
بالتاريخيه ترامب هو من اكثر الشخصيات
شعبيه في الولايات المتحده الان والان غرد
على موقع تروس سوشيال ترامب بانه شعبيته
ارتفعت حوالي 15% لدى النساء ولدى
الجمهوريين ولد الديمقراطيين ايضا مقابل
شعبيه الرئيس الحالي جو بايدن اهم ما يجب
ان نتابعه في الكونجرس ومطالبه
ترامب لاعضاء الجمهوريين في الكونجس لوقف
تمويل وزاره العدل وحتى مكتب التحقيقات
الفيدراليه ولكن
الجمهوريون يقفون صحيح وراء الرئيس ترامب
ولكنهم لن يذهبوا الى هذا الحد الذي يطالب
به ويبقى الحاضر الغائب الابرز هو الصمت
الذي
الزعيم الجمهوري الحياه الكل ما يجري
ورفضه على الاقل دعم الرئيس ترامب باقل
عباره
الجمهوريون قد فعلا قد يستدعوا المدعي
العام
لتحقيق لمزيد من التحقيقات حول استخدام
هذه القضايا كسلاح سياسي ضد الرئيس ترامب
ولكنهم لن يذهبوا الى ابعد من ذلك
وبما يطلبه طبعا الرئيس ترامب منهم في هذه
اللحظات شكرا جزيلا لك اذا نريد سليمان
مراسلات العربيه من واشنطن شكرا
نعود بعد الفصل
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد مباشره ايضا من جديد الى
اقتحام القوات الاسرائيليه مجددا
المسجد الاقصى حيث المعتكفون الفلسطينيون
والمصلون تستخدم الرصاص المطاطي وقنابل
الغاز ضد المصلين في الاقصى وهذه الصور
نتابعها ونتحدث الى زياد لينقل لنا اخر
المعلومات حول هذه المواجهات اذا
هذا صحيح القوات الايطاليه كذا اقتحمت
ساحات المسجد الاقصى وحصلت المصلى القبلي
عمليا منعا لبقاء المعتكفين فيه والسببه
في ذلك لانها عمليا تريد ان تتم
الاقتحامات للمستوطنين صباحا في يوم عيد
الفقه اليهودي بدون ان يكون هناك تواجد
كبير للمصلين الفلسطينيين في داخل المسجد
القدي او في ساعات المسجد الاقصى لهذا تم
الاقتحام تماما كما بالامس بطريقه مشابهه
لجهه القمع والاعتداءات واطلاق الرصاص
المطاطي والقنابل المسيله للنموه والقنابل
الصوتيه يعني هذا المشهد يتكرر ربما
على مشابه لما رايناه بالامس وهذا كان
متوقعا لانه عمليه كما قلت الاسرائيليون
كانوا خططوا لهذا الموضوع من قبل ان يكون
هناك منع للاعتكاف في هذه الادله عن هذه
النقطه اود ان اسالك زياده عن الدعوات من
قبل جماعات يهوديه متطرفه دعت الاقتحام
الاقصى وذبح القرابين داخل باحات وباتسام
طبعا مع عيد الفصحى اليهودي
هذا صحيح جدا وهذا ينتشر مثل النار في
الهشيم في وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي
وبطبيعه الحال هؤلاء المتطرفه
فقط وانما في كل عام تقريبا يحاولون ان
يبدوا جديه في ذلك كما قلت اليوم اعتقل
احد هؤلاء وهو كان يحمل يحمل اضحيه ادعى
بانه اراد ان يدخلها الى الحرم القدسي
وبالتالي هذا الابد يصب الزيت على النار
دائما في مثل هذه الاوقات خاصه في شهر
رمضان الكريم بالاضافه كما قلنا بان هناك
شعور بان الاعتداءات على المسجد الاقصى
لجهه الاقتحامات وايضا حتى عنف الشرطه
الاسرائيليه ذات بفعل هويه من يقف الان
على راس وزاره الامن القومي والمسؤول
المباشر على الشرطه الاسرائيليه لتمر بن
كبير الذي كان بنفسه من هذه الجماعات وما
يزال يحمل نفس الفكر في دعوات الامن
للابقاء على الوضع الراهن كما يسمى والوضع
الراهن له ترتيباته فيما يتعلق بمن يحق له
ان يصلي في الداخل او ان يبقى في الداخل
ومن لا يحق له ذلك والان هناك يعني تحدي
اسرائيلي واضح من قبل بعض الشرائح والفئات
على ما يبدو لو نذكر المشاهدين بهذا
الجانب زياد معك
هذا صحيح عمليا منذ
الوضع الخائن في القدس الشرقيه المحتله
وفيه عمليه من اهل الوصايه على الاماكن
المقدسه على المسجد الاقصى المبارك وعلى
كنيسه القيامه وكل الاماكن المقدسه في
القدس الشرقيه المحتله هي للمملكه
الاردنيه الهاشميه بشكل مباشر
وعمليا لا يحد باحد تغيير الوضع القائم
الذي يعطى فيه الحق في الصلاه في المسجد
الاقصاب فقط للمسلمين
وبطبيعه الحال هذه الاقتحامات هي في
الاساس
نوعا ما لا تتماشى مع
وضع القائم او الساتيكو ولهذا تمنع صلاه
اليهود او ممارسه الشعائر الدينيه
اليهوديه وهذا هو السبب المباشر في هذا
التوتر المستمر لان هذه الاقتحامات تزداد
عمليا وتيره وحجما عندما تكون هناك
مناسبات دينيه يهوديه تمام ولذلك قالت
دائره اوقاف القدس الجهه الاردنيه المشرفه
على شؤون المسجد الاقصى اللي اشرت اليها
زياد باد وصفت هذه التصرفات من الشرطه
الاسرائيليه بانها تعدل صارخ على هويه
ووظيفه المسجد كما كان عباده خاص
بالمسلمين وحدهم زياده كانت صحيفه يدعوت
احروت نقلت عن هناك مسؤول اسرائيلي يقول
بان هناك مساعده دوليه
للتهدئه بعد طبعا اطلاق صواريخ من غزه وما
يحصل لليوم الثاني على التوالي
بالمسجد الاقصى هل من معلومات حول هذه
المساعي
المساعي يمكن ان تكون مؤثره فيما يتعلق
باطلاق الصواريخ في غزه ولكن فيما يتعلق
بالقدس والمسجد الاقصى تقريبا لا قبل لاحد
من الخارج في التاثير كثيرا على الشارع
الفلسطيني بداخل القدس الشرقيه المحتله
الذي عاده يكون في تماس مباشر
من داخل قطاع غزه او غيرها من المناطق هذا
صحيح لهذا قلت بان هناك تاثير على قطاع
غزه وهذا امر مختلف عن ما يحدث في القدس
الشرقيه المحتله وفي المسجد الاقصى لان
هذه الاشتعال في القدس هو ما يفعل عاده
جبهه قطاع غزه هناك بالفعل وسطات والضغوط
مصريه منذ ليله الماضيه على الفصائل وعلى
اسرائيل
لمحاوله احتواء الموقف راينا الفصائل امس
اطلقت اكثر من عشره وهذا امر ايضا يبدو
استثنائيا في المشهد في الاشهر الاخيره
بعد ان جاء يعني جاءت الصور من القمع من
المسجد
الاقصى ولهذا الامور مترابطه بعضها ببعض
وهذه مشكله اسرائيل الاساسيه اصبحت في
السنتين الاخيرتين بان المعادله اصبحت
تربط بين الجبهات بشكل مباشر ما يشتعل في
القدس يشتعل في الضفه يشتعل في الداخل
الخط الاخضر ويشتعل في قطاع غزه كما قلنا
بان هناك عدد من المواقف الدوليه التي
ستتفاعل بدون شك بعد هذا الاقتحام الثاني
اشهرنا قبل قليل الى بعض المواقف الدوليه
والعربيه نذكر بموقف وزاره الخارجيه
السعوديه فجر الاربعاء
الذي اوضح ان المملكه تابعت بقلق بالغ
اقتحام قوات احتلال الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
لباحات المسجد الاقصى الشريف والاعتداء
على المصلين اضافه الى اعتقالها عددا من
المواطنين الفلسطينيين صور جديده يا طاهر
نشاهدها الان من داخل المسجد الاقصى نستمع
الى صوت الطبيعي
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
كنت تتحدث عن ردود الفعل الدوليه ايضا
الرئاسه الفلسطينيه نددت اقتحام المسجد
الاقصى وحذرت من تجاوز الاحتلال للخطوط
الحمراء في الاماكن المقدسه وبان ذلك يمكن
ان يؤدي الى انفجار كبير ايضا دعت كل من
الاردن ومصر الى اجتماع طارق للجامعه
العربيه لبحث هذا التصعيد الاسرائيلي
وايضا تحدثت عن التنديدات العربيه من
المملكه العربيه السعوديه مصر
لتعبر عن رفضها القاطع لهذه الممارسات
التي تقود جهود السلام وتتعارض مع المبادئ
والاعراف الدوليه في احترام المقدسات
الدينيه ايضا حضر وزير الدوله لشؤون الشرق
الاوسط وافريقيا بالخارجيه البريطانيه من
ان ما يحصل قد يؤجج العنفها هو العنف
نشاهده في هذا الشهر الكريم
ولليوم الثاني على التوالي اقتحام للمسجد
الاقصى والمصلين في داخله منصور من رام
الله الخبير في الشان الاسرائيلي اهلا بك
كيف تصف تجدد يعني هذا الاقتحام رغم كل
ردود الفعل الدوليه حتى في بيان نتنياهو
يعني كان وعد بمحاوله منع ذلك
يعني هذا يؤكد على انه ما يحدث هو مبيت
وهو ضد سياسه اسرائيليه مقصوده وليس يعني
جماعات مهووسه دينيه كما يحاول تصويره او
متطرفين او غيرها هذا يجري برعايه الشرطه
من يستحمل اكثر هم شرطه الاحتلال من يعتدي
على المصلين
في شهر رمضان في هذه الايام الفضيله هو من
شرطه الاحتلال ومؤسسه رسميه وايضا لا احد
ياخذ كلام نتنياهو جديه نتنياهو يريد ان
يراود ان يعني يظهر وكان المساله مساله
اجرائيه وليست سياسه تهدف الى خلق نوع من
التقسيم الزماني والمكاني في الاقصى هذا
الوضع ينزل بتفجير الاوضاع بشكل غير مسبوق
وربما على اكثر من جبهه ولا احد يستطيع ان
يتنبا الى اين يمكن ان تصل الامور على
اسرائيل ان تحترم الوضع القائم في القدس
ان تحترم حرمه هذا الشهر الفضيل وانتم يحل
المسلمين ان يمارسوا عبادتهم بكل حريه كما
الديانات الاخرى ما تطلق عليه اسرائيل
تسهيلات هو عمليا او حريه عباده وعمليه
القيود قيود تفرضها على المسلمين وتكسين
زماني هي عندما تخرج المصلين الباحات
الاقصى كي تتيح
للمستوطنين اليهود والمضطرفين اقتحام
الاقصى هذا عمل اعتداء على حريه العبادات
يعني هناك الان قرار يعني جلسه طارئه
لمجلس الامن غدا لبحث الاقتحامات
الاسرائيليه الحاصله الان والمستمره منذ
فجر امس للمسجد الاقصى ما المتوقع منها
يعني كل عام تحصل هذه الاقتحامات بهذا
الشهر الكريم
وتكون هناك جلسه لمجلس الامن واستنكارات
دوليه وعربيه ويتكرر الموضوع
هذا هذا هو تماما البيت القصيد عندما يكون
فقط ادانات واستنكار وتمر الامور هذا
المشهد سيعيد ذاته ويتكرر ونحن امام مشهد
مكرر حرفيا من العام الماضي تماما مثل هذه
الايام حدثت العام الماضي ما حدث اليوم
وايضا في العمل الذي سبق هو هذا كود الى
مواجهه ادت الى يعني اشتعال مواجهه عسكريه
ارتدت لاسبوعين تقريبا لذلك على مجلس
الامن وعلى الدول التي رات تمت في شرم
الشيخ والعقبه تعهدت فيها اسرائيل باحترام
الوضع القائم في القدس وايضا بوقف
عدوانيتها عليهم ان يلزموها بان تنفذ ما
تعاهدت به على هذه القارات ان تتسلح
بمواقف عمليه بخطوات على الارض وبلجم
للسياسه الاسرائيليه بدون ذلك اذا اقتصر
الامر على الادانات نحن نسمع ماذا يقول
بنزير وحتى ننتبه عن هذه هم لا يكون لها
اي بال ويعتبر لها مجرد يعني علاقات عامه
وامر يمكن تجاوزه بعد ايام ولكن ما يحدث
على الارض هو تكريس لسياسه خطيره تمس
بالمسجد الاقصى
باعتقادك نتنياهو قادر على يعني ضبط ايقاع
ان لم يكن تحييد يعني بنكفير
وجماعته وقراراته وهو في منصب رسمي حساس
في هذه الامور
هو يفترض نظريا انه قادر هو رئيس الوزراء
بحكم التوازنات الان لانه هو نتنياهو وضعه
حساس جدا في التحالف الحكومي
في حاله ضعف سياسي شديد نتنياهو يتم
ابتزازه في موضوع الحرس
الوطني الذي شكلوا بنجبير من اجل اخذ
موافقته على تعليق الاصلاحات القضائيه هو
الان ليخضع لهؤلاء الشركاء المتصرفين
ويخضع النزواتهم المتطرفه ومشاريعهم التي
يمكن ان تفجر الاوضاع نعم لتبياهو عدا عن
انه يتماهى مع هذه الجماعات هو جزء من هذه
التركيبه اليمنيه ولكن بحكم خبرته الدوريه
وبحكم خبرته في الطويله في منصب رئاسه
الامور يمكن ان تفجر الاوضاع ولكن هو اضعف
من ان يلجم ويسيطر على هذه الجماعات لذلك
هو يشيرها وهو يعني يفضل حفظ الائتلافه
حكومته على ان تنفجر الامور بالنسبه له
انفجار الامور يمكن الامر يمكن معالجته
وهناك طريقه كيف يمكن الربط يعني بما يحصل
الان مع الازمه السياسيه التي يعيشها
نتنياهو الحكومه التي يتراسها خاصه بعد
الاحتجاجات الاسرائيليه الواسعه التي حصلت
لعده اسابيع وايضا فاشله في التوصل واتخاذ
قرار بما يخص التعديلات القضائيه حتى
الساعه على الاقل يعني كيف يعني يمكن
الربط بين هذا التصعيد والازمه السياسيه
التي يعيشها
يعني لا يمكن تجاهل هذه الازمه السياسيه
نتنياهو يواجه ازمه منذ اسابيع طويله ولكن
هو قبل اسبوع اعلن عن وقت وبعد ذلك هو
يفشل في منع المظاهرات لا احد من
المتظاهرين يصدقه المعارضه والشارع والراي
العام في اسرائيل لا يصدق نتنياهو يدرك
انه يحاول ان يراوغ ان يكسب الوقت ربما
هذا الوضع وتعقيده وعجزه عن امتن
المتظاهرين عن مظاهراتهم ووقفه
للتشريعات ربما يدفع الى هذه الاساليب
لكسب يعني وقت وايضا توحيد الشارع خمسه
نحن نعلم انه الشارع يتوحد عندما يكون
هناك ازمه مع الفلسطينيين او ازمه امنيه
وايضا من مصلحه ان يكون الحديث في وسائل
الاعلام العالميه والداخليه عن ازمه امنيه
وازمه الاقصى بدل ان يكون عن تشريعاته
وقضايا فساده وغيرها لذلك وله مصلحه في
حرف الانظار له مصلحه في توحيد الشارع
الاسرائيلي وحرف اهتمامه وربما هو يغ
[موسيقى]
طبعا ملفات نزهات ولكن اخبار العربيه
مستمره مع الزميره ميسون طبعا ساتتابعينا
ميسون مساء الخير موضوع الاقتحام الثاني
اليوم لقوات الاسرائيليه للمسجد الاقصى
طبعا طاهر العربيه ما زالت مستمره في هذه
التغطيه لهذا التوتر الحاصل وهذا الاقتحام
للمسجد الاقصى لليوم الثاني على التوالي
تفضلي
[موسيقى]